MGM have proposed a different plan for
Stargate and I know what it is welcome
to SRE your Sai TV and movie
[Music]
channel so I told you a couple of weeks
ago and this was actually confirmed by
Jenny styen in MGM Insider on a live
video on Sidra that just over three
weeks ago about three weeks ago there
was a meeting at Amazon now we've talked
lots of times over the last got 18
months or so that there is actually
quite a big disagreement between Amazon
and MGM there's actually disagreement
within Amazon and MGM
Executives but generally speaking MGM
believe that Stargate should return with
a serus and Amazon want a movie now that
disagreement and that debate has been
going on for quite some time
but as we've told you nearly a year ago
now Jennifer suy the head of Amazon
pictures and MGM pictures has decided
that there's going to be a cinematic
movie of Stargate and that's how it's
going to return we were the first here
to tell you about that and we're now the
first to tell you that that plan might
change so what happened three weeks ago
well Jennifer S and a few other
Executives over Amazon agreed to speak
to the people that are suggesting a
series would be a better idea this
Consortium of Executives and people with
big thinking was led by Mike Wright who
is actually the head of MGM plus so they
presented to the
doubters their thinking for what we
should actually do with Stargate and
thanks to a couple of my sources I've
been able to find out what they proposed
so it was a fiveyear
strategy this would start with a
miniseries the basic plan suggested by
MGM was that they would take everything
that has been prepared for towards the
Cinematic movie and switch that into a
three or 4H hour miniseries to Kickstart
the new
franchise that would be followed up by
the Prime series they called it in The
Proposal a prime Stargate series that
would run rough y every 18 months or so
we would get 10 to 15 episodes in that
season and that would basically mean
that we had three seasons within this
initial five-year
phase between each season of this Prime
Stargate series we would get a spin-off
miniseries or series that would be stand
alone this would all culminate in a
movie at the end of that five-year
period this movie would bring everything
together that had been building up
towards and would be the finale of phase
one of the new Stargate
franchise so let's get into this and
tear it apart a little bit first of all
I have to say apparently in this
proposal there was very little sort of
story content shared this wasn't really
about what the story would be and where
the story would go it was more about the
format of the franchise a suggestion
about how they do it not necessarily
what but from what they've suggested
what can we surmise so first of all
switching the movie into a three or 4H
hour miniseries for me think Battlestar
Galactica when that was rebooted it was
almost done as an event now I actually
think when Battlestar Galactica did this
miniseries it was done with the thinking
that they weren't 100% certain how
popular this Rebrand was going to be so
they threw out the initial miniseries to
gauge interest and then when that was
incredibly popular they were more
confident to then green lit the full
series now I don't think that's what
Amazon is thinking here I'm thinking
that MGM have suggested this because one
they don't want to waste the work that's
been done on the movie two this actually
means that they have a script and they
have already an idea how they wanted to
Kickstart the franchise with the
Cinematic movie so again why waste it
but three from what I'm being told this
movie was going to be looking at three
hours long and they were looking at ways
to try and trim that down Amazon wanted
a 2-hour movie the story though was
getting longer and longer and longer as
the writer who I actually know who that
was now but I'll put a pin in that for
now because I'm not 100% confident the
writer was basically trying to add more
and more background to make the story
make sense and the film was steadily
just getting longer and longer so mgm's
thinking is let's just let the writer do
what they want to do and let's do a
three or 4our
miniseries also though Amazon could
really throw this out as a big event
they would promote the hell out of this
miniseries and it' be something that we
Gators could binge in a night
potentially they would really throw
everything into it and they would
produce it as a miniseries it would
probably get released on DVD it would
100% get released on electrical version
as well to download they would really
try and package it as the big scale
return of
Stargate a 4our movie at the cinema
wouldn't really work but as a miniseries
dropped on Amazon in maybe a day that
would actually get Gators really excited
and it would give the marketing and PR
people something to really focus on to
get the ball rolling and to get the
excitement
built the other point about doing a
miniseries is it could be done much
quicker they don't have to quite go to
the level of detail Etc that you would
demand in a movie it's something that
they could potentially get as screens
within 12 months and that is another big
reason why it's potentially a very
exciting proposal for us
Gators so beyond the miniseries though
we're talking about a Prime series that
would be the main Stargate series that
everything else would basically surround
follow now I still suspect this will be
an sg1 reboot or revamp now I don't mean
that will be a lot of the sg1 stars
coming back even though I'm certain one
or two will but I think the format of
sg1 that's the kind of show we're going
to get it's going to be teams going
through the gate going on Starships
occasionally blah blah blah I think the
main overarching story that is being
built up towards when they end phase one
will be basically centered around that
series that that series will be the main
driving force for the
story now looking at this being every 18
months and maybe 10 maybe 15 episodes
from what I'm being told is they would
basically give the creators free reain
really to have as many episodes in that
season as the story required I could
imagine we'll see 12 13 9 whatever but
the main reason why those Seasons would
be 18 months apart is I'm hoping because
they really do expect these series to be
very high quality that they would be
looking at almost theatrical level
quality and that is just very difficult
to do annually I mean we're seeing that
with a lot of other series at the moment
that we don't get a new season every
year we seem to be get them every two
and maybe even three years sometimes and
it seems to be that the MGM would plan
ahead with that that they would expect
that quality to be there and that they
understand that actually that would take
a little bit longer than we would like
but if the MGM get their way it doesn't
mean that we would go 18 months without
something new because in between each of
the Prime series of Stargate they plan
Standalone separate either miniseries or
full seasons now I don't have a lot of
detail about what that means so I'm
speculating quite a lot now but I do
think there's a logical assumption to be
made here if you have an overarching
storyline something that they're
building up towards in phase one then
you could have prequels or you could
have seasons of things that are away
from the main show so again just
spitball in here say there's a new
threat say it's the fings because that's
an ongoing joke and ask serious that the
evil Ewoks are going to come back but
say it's the fings ings the fings are to
they attack us or they try to do
whatever it is evil they're trying to do
we don't understand it so then you have
the first season of the Prime show sort
of explaining the new threat and sort of
World building you then perhaps have a
prequel Series going back to the
Ancients that explains why the fings are
behaving the way they are you also then
may be have a jaffan series which
explains the threat from a different
perspective you could even then maybe
have another season actually that
explains things from the new villains
perspective the furlings perspective you
could do lots of things that would added
depth to the overarching story line this
is kind of what Marvel did they did lots
and lots of stores that were all
building towards the Thanos battle in
the end we saw The Finity stones in lots
of different guises and in lots of
different ways before Thanos ever got
his hands on them and I think Stargate
could be planning to do something
similar it's such a big universe that we
could really get to see the one story
from lots of different directions and
this idea of having sort of Standalone
Series in between the Prime series for
me is a very interesting Prospect
assuming that that's what they're
thinking and then all of this would
build up towards the dramatic inclusion
the movie now whether that was released
to cinema or direct to Prime at this
point I don't really
care to be honest any director Prime
movie tends to be near if not theatrical
level of quality anyway so really it
wouldn't make a difference to me whether
I watched it at home on my tell or I
watched it the cinema or hey you know
what well they've started to do quite a
lot recently both release it in the
cinema in a limited way and put it on
Prime almost immediately
do that I don't care as long as I get to
see it I love the idea though of having
sort of a dramatic conclusion that
Avengers moment built up over five years
I love the idea that there is this
Five-Year Plan for a franchise like
Stargate and that they're not just going
to crack on and do something they're
actually going to do something with a
final goal in mind for me I think that's
when Marvel would at its best when it
had the infinity Saga in its vision and
they had something to stay focused upon
after the infinity Saga they wandered a
little bit it feels like and it feels
like even though this plan is a little
bit more focused and a little bit more
what we're used to nowadays with stream
and series Etc it does feel like it
still is
stargame now this was only a proposal by
MGM we don't actually yet know what the
Amazon Executives thought of it but the
fact that the Executives were at least
willing to have the conversation at this
point before the actors return to work
and they actually have to get started
does suggest they're at least open to
the
possibility
93% of gators when we asked them told us
that they want a series not a movie
first and if Amazon are good for
anything they're pretty good at giving
the customer what they want but what do
you think about mgm's proposal get into
the comments is it an exciting Five-Year
Plan or does it leave you feeling a bit
flat get to the comments and tell me
exactly what you think as well as tell
me what sort of storylines you hope they
will include what do you think the main
villain should be let your imaginations
run right and again get to the comments
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also please go to
patreon.com most of our new videos
premere first and you get to see them
without the adverts also go to
s.co which is our dedicated website
where we do articles based on most of
our videos and we try to add a little
bit more detail for you to digest go and
check it out as always please stay safe
and I'll see you next
[Music]
time